I have never seen anything like what I
am about to play for you
Kanye West went on something called
drink Champs
and delivered one of the most
anti-Semitic rants against the Jewish
people that I have ever seen in the sort
of modern media era short of actual
Nazis and it's basically there
Kanye West in controversy lately I won't
go through the entire thing he's a
musical artist he was recently wearing
white lives matter gear and then he went
on the Tucker Carlson show and said a
whole bunch of stuff including
anti-semitic stuff which got cut out but
which we ultimately obtained and looked
at last week
let's go through this and I'm telling
you
I have I have not seen anything like
this in the modern era short of from
over white supremacist Nazis let's just
jump right in and I will stop it and
talk about some of the things he says uh
we made the white lives matter tease and
then when I put up the the Tweet the
Defcon tweet nah he ain't he ain't
releasing the teeth because he's Jewish
and I'm like see this is my exact point
that I'm making like Jewish people have
owned the black voice what
Jewish people have owned the black boys
you know it's interesting because
Kanye's recent thing over the last few
years has been black folks have no one
to blame but ourselves for slavery which
is like a crazy thing to say but now all
of a sudden he's actually found
something better his first thing was
black folks we should just blame
ourselves for everything bad now he's
actually saying oh you know it's Jews
let's blame Jews
um the truth is Jewish folks have been
one of the Premier partners for black
folks in the United States
to demand and obtain quality rights
self-determination Jewish folks have
been killed in fact depend defending and
supporting black folks remember the
movie Mississippi Burning but the
murders of black rights activists in
Mississippi
sometimes people see the names and they
get confused because the victims were
James Chaney and Andrew Goodman and
Michael schwerner and people will look
at that and say Goodman and schwerner
those aren't exactly typical black names
that's right they were Jewish men from
New York City because the uh Jewish
activists were so intertwined with the
Civil Rights Movement the history is so
intertwined Kanye is way off track now
let's continue whether it's through US
wearing a Ralph Lauren
shirt okay
Ralph Lauren shirts so I realize that
for me all this stuff I'm familiar with
every one of these things but for a lot
of people they don't know what Ralph
Lauren what do you mean why Ralph Lauren
Ralph Lauren the designer was born Ralph
lifshitz a Jewish guy from New York City
so
Kanye says wearing Ralph Lauren it's
another way in which Jews are
controlling us well why not Tommy
Hilfiger I mean black folks like other
people also wear Tommy Hilfiger well
Tommy Hilfiger is Jewish so it's not
interesting to Kanye Ralph Lauren is
Jewish so that is more interesting or as
all of us being signed to a record label
or having a Jewish manager or being
assigned to a Jewish basketball team
what is a Jewish basketball team
he doesn't mean an Israeli I mean
there's an Israeli professional
basketball league that's not what he
means does he mean a team where the
owner is Jewish or the general manager
or what what is this Jewish basketball
team and you know there is this for
people who care about this stuff there
is a very important historical story
about how Jews were pushed into certain
professions there were all sorts of
Industries in which Jews were just not
allowed to participate and what happened
was there was a period where the
industries Jews were allowed to
participate in were the ones wherein the
the sort of learning and training could
kind of happen on your own like a bunch
of a bunch of Jews not allowed to do a
whole bunch of other stuff they could
get together and talk about you know
whatever is it the law is it whatever
and so the very discrimination against
Jews created an environment in which
Jews were pushed towards certain
industries The Conspiracy to control
those Industries is where it gets
completely anti-semitic but there is a
discrimination history that talks about
and explains why you saw Jews push
towards certain industries anyway this
stuff is really nuts or doing a movie on
a Jewish platform like Disney okay what
is a Jewish platform like Disney Walt
Disney
was not only not Jewish he had a
reputation for being very anti-semitic
Walt Disney so I don't know how it's now
a Jewish platform like the current
president of Disney is Bob chapek maybe
he's Jewish I don't know I don't know
whether Kanye knows that
uh it's it's really nuts and we
understand it's like I I respect what
the Jew Jewish people have done and how
what have they done they brought their
people together you know they came into
money uh through the lawyers oh boy
oh boy when uh after Wall Street when um
what does that mean after Wall Street
when all of the uh like the Catholics
they wouldn't they wouldn't divorce
people so that's truly bongers Jewish
lawyers came into money by divorcing
people when the Catholics wouldn't I I
found no evidence of that so the Jewish
lawyers came and they were willing to
divorce people that's when they first
came into their money so like say with
me and Jay our our culture with the with
the darker Jews first of all cause you
got it happens when anybody starts
talking deep okay yeah yeah with the
dark with the darker Jews the 12 lost
tribes of Israel so remember I explained
this last week this is the black
Israelite stuff black Israelites are a
group that believe they are truly the
Jews
um it's often a very racist set of
beliefs we are because we Jewish also
we're from Africa also we're the blood
of Christ so now if you're confused by
that last line it's Bonkers I won't even
get into it and that's just black we are
a Jew just like the Jewish people and
now we're coming into money but the main
thing is I gotta drink the Ducey over
the Hennessy
as the first step to us coming together
like how the Jewish people came together
but we couldn't even talk about I
remember Ben Horowitz called me after
444 and said I don't know about Jay
giving up business Jewish business
secrets and these secrets okay Ben Ben
Horowitz I oh I mean listen there's no
evidence that that happened I guess it's
hard to comment on something so insane
we took my um building up the uh the
properties and stuff like that these
secrets can't they not what he's arguing
is that Ben Horowitz who's a venture
capitalist and Jewish presumably because
his last name is Horowitz I'm assuming
he's saying he called up Jay-Z when
Jay-Z was starting I guess to make
investments in real estate I assume by
Jay he means Jay-Z and told him that's a
Jewish Business secret right buying real
estate that's that's a secret I have
never seen anything like this I have
never seen anything like this and you
can of course say oh it's it's simply
mental illness well sure I mean he
sounds mentally ill in a lot of
different ways
but he has become fixated with Jews in a
way that is reminiscent of the worst of
the worst of the worst anti-semites we
will have that clip on our Instagram at
davidpackman show hard to find a true
word in that segment
right now many of us are asking
ourselves what's the best way to help
the people affected by the recent
hurricanes and the truth is giving them
cash is one of the best things you can
do because cash is so cost effective
when you give families cash you're also
empowering them to choose for themselves
how to best improve their situation and
I've talked before about our sponsor
give directly give directly is a
non-profit that just lets donors like
you send cash directly to families who
need it the most give directly is a
great organization I've been following
for years a lot of their focus is on
impoverished families in Africa but
right now give directly is also allowing
you to send cash directly to families
impacted by hurricanes Ian and Fiona
during Hurricane Ian more than two and a
half million people were ordered to
leave their homes expenses are rising
they need food shelter Transportation
hurricane Fiona hit Puerto Rico on
September 18th more than 12 000 people
displaced the island is still in a state
of emergency and people need help visit
give directly.org Pacman to learn more
and send money directly to someone who
needs it the link is down below